everyone is so sexed up on that show
people I'm sure people were sitting at
home jerking off to that show being like
Oh
[Music]
tonight at the 12 guests of Christmas at
the Gramercy Theatre also December 2nd
and 3rd at Largo in Los Angeles ESO has
a show getting dug with high where he
smokes weed with comedians on YouTube
super fun real quick before when I did
your show I literally the next morning
when I was doing MADtv we shot a sketch
where we were playing pot heads at 7:00
a.m. and I was still so baked from your
show it was kind of but then also
terrible because I was just like at
first I got that I was like it would be
great because I'm still I'm really still
up and we're doing a show we're
playing a pot heads doing a cooking show
up to play yeah and then we
started Amir K and I would start
improvising and he would just look at me
and I was like oh is that not funny he's
like dude you up and I was like
can we take 10 oh my god
Doug Benson is in studio with me and Tom
took our Benson who I have been a huge
fan of since best week ever days Doug
Benson used to steal the show every week
on best week ever I'll never forget one
line that has stayed with me since 2006
I remember probably 2005 it was some
story about Paris Hilton and it was like
she was leaving someplace and you were
like hey Paris don't let the door have
sex with you on the way out I remember
like me and my friends loved it so much
and then I got on Last Comic Standing my
senior year of and Doug was like one of
my favorite comedians of like I used to
make lists of like I was so obsessed
with comedy Doug was always on
like my top favorite comedians still is
funniest just one of the funniest people
ever and then I go to Last Comic
Standing
my senior year I get passed at the
Chicago auditions and I go to LA for the
semi-finals and Doug Benson is in the
the lobby of the Hilton Garden Inn in
Glendale where they were putting us
during the show and I go vest Doug
Benson what is he doing here and I went
up to go say I'm a fan I love you and I
go why are you here and he was like I'm
doing less constant and like I'm
competing against you it was like it was
like me and Tinashe pretty much is how I
felt it was like me meeting Alexis rent
on the first day of Dancing with the
Stars I was like why am I here you do
meet like a lot of people through doing
these shows like I met TIG that time it
was it was Todd on that one
no no Todd's on the very first one and
then he was also on that weird battle of
the first and second seasons where they
they didn't announce the winner on TV
they just mentioned it during a during
an ad during like some during like an
animated it was a premiere of a new
animated show in a bombing but they just
mentioned it during a break and in
another show yeah there were a lot of
people there that that season that was
so fun remember how they said they
sequestered us when we we were we're at
the point where we nobody there was like
40 comedians we're all gonna compete to
see who makes it into the next top ten
yeah and when so we had to stay in a
hotel room for we were sequestered in a
hotel for a couple of days we had
roommates yeah yeah my roommate was
Chris Porter mine was Jackie Casey who
advanced and then you still have to stay
there one more night after they announce
who's advance and who has it so I had to
be roommates with a guy who was
celebrating all night long because he
had advanced and I didn't make it yeah
and I didn't that's what happened is
then I came back the next year and
that's when I made it into the into the
next group and and that's where I met
Amy Schumer and that's where we became
friends yes and yeah but this season
where you and I were there remember
Shawn rouse was there yes he passed away
recently
hilarious dude they wouldn't let us out
at night and the bar closed at 10:00 so
we wanted drinks so he figured out oh
I'm gonna and they have some they had
somebody posted at the front door in the
hotel
yeah so he ordered a pizza from dominos
and when the guy got there at the hotel
room door he said can I give you extra
money for your shirt and for your hat
and he bought the guy's shirt and hat
and then and and left the you know the
hotel like he had just delivered pizzas
yeah and that's how he got out
oh wait he do with the other guy just
get past the Last Comic Standing
chaperone person yeah that was watching
the door and so so he skated out that
way but then I met him at the bar
because there's the hotel at a back door
so I such elaborate likes to get out and
then we just went to a bar nearby a drag
drag for hours yeah it was very very
strange experience Josh wolf was also uh
he was we had we had like adjoining
doors between the rooms so Chris Porter
type I think was Ty Burnett
yeah his name and Josh wolf like we just
opened up the adjoining door in the four
of us would all just smoke weed every
night you know like it's so funny how
that show they they try to control you
but they don't it's not the same as
other reality shows usually you can get
away with a lot of me and Amy used
to take when you have to go and get in a
small bus to go to events and stuff we
just fill a coffee cup with booze in the
hotel bar and just sit there drinking
out of look like we're drinking coffee
yeah but vodka drips through paper cuts
through the paper starts to drip so you
got a drink it fast yeah it's real weird
because I put it in my body all the time
and then liver stronger than a cup yeah
that was the vibe when I came back for
the finale of Dancing with the Stars
like everyone's just like drinkin and
smokin like in their trailers and before
that because we have nothing to lose
we're not trying to lay the rules are
all still in place but no one's
following them anymore we're just
kind of some of us aren't showing up for
dress rehearsal because we know we just
have to stand there and watch it was so
much more fun and I've told this before
but when I got eliminated from Last
Comic Standing I was still in college
and I had to go back and like do tests
and like go back to class the next week
and I was like I don't want to go and I
was having a cigarette with Brendon
Walsh II would also get eliminated that
night we were outside the Glendale
Hilton and I was like I don't wanna go
back to school tomorrow and he's like
just tell them you're still on the show
just like they're not it's not gonna air
till the summer so just tell them that
you're still so I just did I emailed
them and I said I'm still on the show
and I'm in LA and they were like follow
your dream girl and then I just they
didn't have to go back to school ever
cuz then it was over and they never knew
and it was it was such a brilliant plan
but I might be finding out right now
I'm sorry thank you for believing me but
then we did you know after that shortly
after that you started opening for me on
the road stuff that was awesome that
really took everything to the next level
was and that's the only way you can get
to the next level is having a headliner
take you to feature for them and then
getting that amount of stage time so
that was like that was so rad we got I
got in so many places through you like
so many clubs that I still work to this
day first time going there was with Doug
Benson so I always I always um I owe you
a lot Doug you were the first guy to
bring me on the road the and that's mean
something because then other people
start bringing you on the road because
then you get better because someone took
the chance but I remember the first time
I opened for Doug I didn't have 20
minutes I was terrified and but then you
get it together because someone believes
in you it takes one person to believe in
you
that's what Lady Gaga's had sixteen
hundred times in an interview if there's
a room of a hundred people and 99 don't
believe in you Doug Benson was the one
who believed in me Doug Benson was that
person for me thank you remember that
show we did it Morty's that one night
where the entire audience was as they
say urban it was a black crowd because
they gave away tickets on the local
urban radio station no I don't remember
this
did not go well the host was a black guy
he killed oh right then you had a hard
time after him and then I had meant so
much to be working it out Anthony
Jeselnik used to bomb in front of me
like people would walk people that would
just get up and leave like I'm not even
stay for Doug Benson right because this
guy is making so much from Doug Benson
on the road first of all and things that
I still do on the road which is like you
don't put like you like everything just
to be in or you expect a lot from clubs
because it doesn't take much to just
deliver a good experience it really is
so easy and when they it up
it's really annoying and I don't like it
and I don't stand for it anymore because
I've seen you how you handle those
situations and you'll go in and be like
guys but like I just call out things
like if my right if my veggie tray isn't
there I get annoyed cuz how hard is it
to get a vegetarian and it's the
only thing I asked for I'm not asking
for a pair of new Nikes but some people
are yeah you had to go to Schnucks or
what it's a grocery store in st. Louis
but you know in st. Louis but also
another thing I learned about you which
I from you that I love and I don't know
if you still do this but like you would
you would get offstage at like you would
be like I'm doing a 45 minute show maybe
50 minute and I don't need these guys
that do hour and a half's and like it's
just what are you hiding from offstage
you they never want to get offstage
running from in your life windings calls
would you have to return if you got
offstage exactly when Dane Cook are all
the Carlos Mencia suet 2:7 he did seven
hours last night why don't you want to
go home go home like as an audience
member
show me my favorite Canadian I would
have
staff the waitstaff has to just sell
cokes or nothing after last call
comedian goes all night and they have to
stay socks in case somebody their table
wants another coat and so they're
sitting around all night and they're not
getting tips that reflect the amount of
time there's Brian and people and
audiences have such social anxiety that
they can't even go to the bathroom
during a show because they're worried
that the comedian's gonna call them out
or everyone in the room will look at
them so people are holding in their pee
the whole show already and then you push
that you're just putting people it is a
hostage situation no one's like a few
people are social grace hostage
situation where it's like people who are
polite you're holding them hostage yes
that's a great idea we should just take
a break at some point in the set does
anyone need to use the restroom raise
your head I actively when someone stands
up and like and you can tell that I
actively like turn the other way I hate
that I can't help myself I always
mention it but it's not I try not to
shame them for having to use the
bathroom yeah I try to make it more on
me like I always say something like oh
yeah you're right this is a good time
sure
if it feels like something that is not
political and they stand up I'm like oh
I'm sorry I offended the corne fans but
like in general I just like I know that
you probably have to you don't want
to deal with me right now
I hate when a comedian calls out a girl
and is like she's just going to Shu and
taking a dub big gnarly dumb let's
listen everybody
I follow somebody in the bathroom and
just like stand outside the door while
they use the bathroom getting dug with
hi you're still doing that you've been
doing that show a while on YouTube yeah
we just celebrated our fifth anniversary
why we celebrated by smoking some weed
oh yeah people that do that show get so
but even before we added that
segment people were just and I
definitely have you know I try not to
have much to do after idea kind of kind
of ruins the rest of the day because
it's just you're just there's a it's not
just standing around casually smoking -
you're high it's smoking - you're high
and then you just kind of have to push
through and keep going yeah because
we're live for 45 minutes
and people just start calling you a
in the comments I like get so
Vytas I'm back on the weed train doug
has asked me to do it before and I'm
like I'm not smoking weed now or I'm
like I I am but I don't want to be
public about it or whatever and now I'm
back on the weed train but I like I
guess yeah have you taken do you still
take breaks do you still do sober
October that kind of thing I do but not
from a narrative breaking weed it's just
alcohol I don't I don't know that I need
a break from wheat like I feel very
similar to you with weed is that it's
like it makes me work harder do you feel
like it's a stimulant for you in a way
uh you know I smoke all day every day so
I guess you know and I manage to get
some things done yeah you know any time
you get really high you know you either
you're like you get ambitious but that
you might be ambitious to do nothing you
know I mean like you might be like I'm
really gonna hunker down and not get up
right now yeah you know like like like
if I don't have plans throughout the day
if I have like a totally free day and
the first thing I do is get high then
I'll spend the next 3-4 hours trying to
figure out what the to do yep yeah
I mean and I end up not doing anything
productive it's just you know it's like
walking around in a Blockbuster video
store and then
without picking a movie you can't you
just can't when I have stuff to do all
day I could just get high in between the
things and yet be high and do the things
I need to do
that's sort of what props me up like I
joke around about how like I like to
take pictures of fans after the shows
because they're holding me up yeah
thanks for holding me up for a few
minutes
well your friends think it's out how to
work a camera I mean that's the
other have you noticed the thing of when
people take pictures after shows how
rude some of the people that you you
want to like your fans and then they're
so rude to the guy taking pictures who's
not being paid to do it I mean except
we're tipping them at the end of the
week or whatever but they don't know
that and this person's just like taking
Bish's and they go it's blurry do you
not know how to work an iPhone and I go
I hate you know and I don't want to take
a second picture I so often I think a
lot of people are assholes yeah it's it
surprises me how many women it's usually
women that are just like I look
disgusting in this have you ever taken a
picture before and hands it back to them
and I go don't talk to him that way
yeah paying him I pushed for selfies
selfie yes let's do it and if they're
all shaky I just grab it and do it
myself
dude selfies I can't agree with you more
people wish on selfies like oh dude
gooo selfie I'm like why it's the most
efficient way to take a picture what's
the alternative handing it to someone
bothering someone to take it it and it's
a better picture because this faces
you're selling the faces unless they're
wearing like a Dancing with the Stars
outfit or something you don't need the
body people take pictures from so far
back and then cameras also still the
camera phones like iPhones everything
still looks further away than it
actually is you could be the front row
at a concert and want to post a picture
and it looks like you're like sitting
far away take a picture of a full moon
you are back on the weed drain
I can't get a picture of the full moon I
don't have opposable thumbs selfies I am
so on board with selfies just it's so
much quicker and easier and like passing
the phone off to another person the
person takes it and it's a phone they've
never used before so they gotta figure
it out and then they gotta go okay
one two they also drill it sometimes
they'll drill it so they've got 12
pictures of you with your eyes closed
and three with your eyes open
and guess which one they're gonna use
for me the one where I look the most
stone they tagged you I take a weekend
and two people why did you even I always
tell people to also and before the
curtain came up this young couple a man
and a woman came up to me and she was
like can I can we get a selfie with you
sorry to bother you no problem so I
stand up and when you take a selfie and
then this lady comes up my daughter's
mad at me because I want a picture - I
don't know who you are but I want a
picture cuz she got one but now she's
not talking to me just like refusing to
speak - why do you have to embarrass me
like that she needed a picture she
doesn't know my daughter got a picture
so I need one - Doug if people want to
get high with you or get you high
because I think that's the thing if
you're Doug Benson fan your dream is
like I want to smoke weed with Doug
Benson I want to get him high I want to
roll like great racket that that's
people's dream yeah - give me weed and
smoke with me that is not exaggeration
it is a true dream of potheads to do
that and they and I've seen it happen
and I can only imagine it's gotten even
more so over the years what is the best
way for them to do that
the most efficient way for someone to
get you high and to have an experience
with you and to not be annoying and to
walk away with you being like that guy
was a good guy just be standing next to
me is what I like to say okay if you
want to get me to smoke with you I mean
unless we're like in an airport or
something and we can't do it but if I'm
anywhere where we can get away with it
I'll smoke with anybody but what kind of
conversation do you want to avoid what
kind of questions have you been asked
too many times like well yes I don't
know when the fan comes up and just
starts asking if they ask about
something specific that like I never
hear about or that oh yeah this is kind
of a fun thing to tell you the answer to
then that's fine but a lot of times it's
just you know so where are you going
next what's you know they just it's just
very generic and then I'm just like well
I mean you know just go look at my
Twitter or whatever yeah about that all
the time let's have a real you know
conversation but you know I'm just
that's a great thing about smoking pot -
is it you can get a bunch of fans at
once
so we're all in a big circle and then I
can say things that make everybody laugh
and they feel like they're getting an
extra performance yeah and it's just you
know it's a good time you're like the
Bert Kreischer of weed whereas people
would drink with him with his shirt off
Doug likes to keep his coat on and smoke
weed with his fans after shows
[Music]
you